[Musique]
ouais
elle
ce sont les nouvelles stars du disco
mais qui pourrait croire que ces
danseurs sont des criminels endurcis
[Applaudissements]
nous ne sommes pas dans une salle de
spectacle mais dans une prison
entre ses murs les détenus purgent tous
de longues peines des meurtriers des
violeurs des trafiquants de drogue qui
semble devenu doux comme des agneaux une
métamorphose rendue possible grâce à ce
que l'on appelle ici la dance thérapie
[Musique]
pour assister au show il faut aller aux
philippines et plus précisément ces
boues
lille est une destination touristique
mais sa capitale cebu city est loin
d'être un paradis
pauvreté et criminalité le lot quotidien
du million d'habitants
sur les collines qui dominent la ville
la prison centrale
connu ici sous le nom de cp dr c'est une
enceinte ultra sécurisé et derrière les
barreaux mille six cents détenus
cette prison est l une des pires du pays
réputée pour sa violence ses règlements
de comptes et ses trafics en tous genres
et puis il ya deux ans tout bascule avec
l'arrivée d'un nouveau directeur il est
devenu une célébrité aux philippines son
nom est écrit sur sa chemisette byron
alias byron garcia
c'est quoi ce tatouage un diable c'est
interdit ici
tu aurais dû dessiner un ange un vrais
anges de dieu
ancien responsable d'une usine
d'armement byron garcia ne connaissait
rien à l'univers carcéral à son arrivée
c'est le chaos des armes et de la drogue
dans l'enceinte même de la prison et une
seule loi celle des gangs
le plus difficile a été sans aucun doute
le démantèlement des gangs c'était notre
priorité à l'époque
tekori balayé la culture des gangs
débarrasser des gangs les détenus
pouvaient souffler
et on pouvait créer un nouveau système
pour y parvenir il place les chefs de
gangs en isolement des caméras
surveillent qu'aujourd'hui le moindre
recoin et il fait le ménage parmi les
gardiens 42 d'entre eux sont licenciés
pour corruption d'emblée la situation
s'améliore mais pour combien de temps
je savais que tôt ou tard les gangs
pouvait se reconstituer
je cherchais vraiment quelque chose pour
les occuper un programme où tout le
monde devait participer se sentir
impliqué
d'habitude on occupe les détenus en leur
faisant faire du sport mais byron
trouvais qu'il manquait d'entrain c'est
là qu'il a eu l'idée de les faire danser
sur du disco bien sûr tous n'étaient pas
d'accord mais les réfractaires été
sanctionné
pendant la première année j'ai été dur
avec eux
il fallait être dur pour obtenir de
quelque chose
ensuite j'ai été moi même étonné que ça
marche
et la transformation des prisonniers a
été très rapide
pour les faire danser byron a recruté
guen danseuse professionnelle devenue la
chorégraphe de la prison
tous les jours à l'est avec les
prisonniers
quatre heures de danse obligatoire pour
tout le monde
[Musique]
maintenant on refait la même formation
où sont les filles quelques manques chez
les hommes allez tous en place
très tôt
dès le réveil à 6h du matin et l'après
midi pendant deux heures hommes et
femmes mélangés les criminels se
prennent au jeu
[Musique]
le doigt
aujourd'hui tout est bien rodée mais
pour ben c'était loin d'être gagné au
début
la première fois que j'ai su que je
devais faire danser des prisonniers
j'étais très inquiet
j'ai dit à monsieur byron que je ne
voulais pas le faire car ce sont des
meurtriers et on ne sait pas de quoi ils
sont capables
les résultats sont spectaculaires
les prisonniers semble ravi de leur
nouvelle activité même si nous n'avons
pas eu le droit de les interroger seul
chris antho devenu le danseur étoile de
la troupe a été autorisée nous par les
récentes aux 37 ans partage sa cellule
avec 17 détenus ici depuis six ans pour
trafic de drogue il attend toujours son
jugement
gruissan taux était lui même accro au
crack à son arrivée
tout est tellement différent maintenant
depuis qu'on danse j'ai changé
physiquement avant j'étais toujours de
mauvaise humeur irritable lille et
l'aréna ronald approchable d'iron nous a
tout changé
avant nous étions dégâts terribles mais
quand il est arrivé il nous a traités
autrement
je suis devenu quelqu'un d'autre avant
ma famille n'aimait pas venir me voir
maintenant ils viennent régulièrement
gruissan taux a connu l'avant byron
aujourd'hui comme les autres détenus de
cebu il peut circuler librement dans la
prison
et mec est sûre qui veulent défier aux
échecs
les verrous ont sauté
l'ambiance s'est détendue
je ne suis plus accro à la drogue depuis
longtemps déjà j'ai oublié à quoi ça
ressemble son goût son odeur regardez
moi je suis en pleine santé maintenant
pour beaucoup de prisonniers byron
garcia est plus qu'un directeur
certains en font même un gourou ils vont
jusqu'à se faire tatouer son nom sur la
peau
monsieur byron est mon idole
difficile à croire mais ce culte semble
sincère
j'ai fait faire ce tatouage car byron a
fait plein de bonnes choses pour nous je
le vénère pour la façon dont ils nous
traitent
ils me voient comme une figure
paternelle maintenant
quelqu'un qui peut les disciplines et
qui peut s'occuper d'eux
ils ont eu beaucoup d'autres directeurs
de prison avant moi
mais aucun d'entre eux n'avait changé si
radicalement leur vie
[Musique]
c'est sûrement pour cette raison que des
centaines d'entre eux au moment tatoué
sur leur corps
[Musique]
ce soir concentration maximale dans la
cour de la prison
byron garcia est venu superviser la
danse une répétition générale
dans 48 heures c'est le grand spectacle
mensuel devant le public
[Musique]
pyramides humaines
chorégraphie martial tout est calculé au
pad dans ce prêt
la magie du disco au père
[Musique]
pas de place pour l'impro pas question
de décevoir le grand manitou
chris santos se donne à fond dans deux
jours l'ancien trafiquant de drogue va
danser devant sa femme et son fils
et sa famille et la première stupéfaite
de sa métamorphose
avant d'être en prison crise en eaux
vives est ici à minganie à un bidonville
situé aux portes de ces boues pour sa
femme clé off on n'est pas loin du
miracle
je ne pouvais plus le comprendre et son
taux était drogué sous crack est
toujours très irritable
ils étaient cruelles et on n'arrêtait
pas de se disputer mais maintenant qu'il
est en prison il a complètement changé
on dirait qu'il revit
une résurrection suivi au jour le jour
par cleo off qui conserve précieusement
les coupures de journaux qui parlent de
crise antho ça s'écrit son taux et sa
c'est wayne jean dans la presse son mari
a quitté la rubrique des faits divers
pour les pages culturelles le changement
est radical
je suis fier de lui de ce qu'il est
devenu car il est heureux maintenant nos
voisins me disent toujours ton marier
très célèbre c'est le danseur étoile du
cp drc
cri santo a toujours aimé danser
c'est un super danseurs
le dernier samedi du mois le jour j les
premiers bus arrive des centaines de
personnes sont attendues
l'entrée est gratuite
dans la foule des touristes la prison
devient une attraction
pour les détenus c'est déjà presque une
routine mais le directeur n'entend pas
relâcher la pression
bonjour un chacun d'entre vous mes chers
prisonniers
je dois vous dire que ce matin je suis
très nerveux
car vous avez l'air trop sûr de vous
vous êtes tous souriants appliquez-vous
aujourd'hui nous avons plein de
visiteurs et le dernier bus est en train
d'arriver
dernières recommandations
un seul mot d'ordre ne pas décevoir le
public
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est parti pour une heure et demie
de show
[Musique]
sous un soleil de plomb une succession
de tubes
ambiance années 80 chorégraphie
impeccable
chris antho est aux anges il en
oublierait presque les grilles sa
famille est aux premières loges chaque
mois il attend ces instants là avec
impatience
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le show touche à sa fin byron garcia
veut montrer qu'il n'y a plus aucun
problème de sécurité dans sa prison la
preuve il autorise les visiteurs à
prendre la pose avec les détenus
pour chris santos et l'heure des
retrouvailles
[Musique]
je suis heureuse à chaque fois que je le
vois danser je suis très fier de lui
[Musique]
byron lui soigne son public mission
accomplie une fois encore il a compris
les touristes
c'était génial je n'ai jamais rien vu de
pareil dans ma vie
les philippins sont vraiment très
différent de nous ce serait difficile de
faire ça en europe mais je pense qu'il
faudrait essayer quand même
[Applaudissements]
unique au monde les méthodes de byron
garcia commence à être prise au sérieux
des spécialistes américains sont déjà
venus observer de près le phénomène la
dance thérapie en prison pourrait bien
faire des émules
[Musique]
un succès qui a de quoi donner la grosse
tête au directeur il n'y a qu'à voir le
clou du spectacle une parade des grandes
figures du xxème siècle
après granddi le dallai lama jean paul 2
nelson mandela ou lady di la dernière
effigie arrive
en toute simplicité byron garcia un
directeur de prison un brin mégalo